look north Kosh says he can't afford to
pay the rent of his one-room home he is
an office assistant at a state-owned
telecom provider which has run into
large losses and is among thousands of
workers who have not been paid their
salaries for eight months I have a small
daughter I'm unable to pay her school
fees her tuition fees
now he has turned to his Union for help
under the terms of a government bailout
his employer is reported to be
considering shedding 80,000 jobs that's
half its workforce and Kosh is worried
that as a contractual worker he will be
among the first to go but he's been told
that the union has not even been
consulted by the company's management
the unions say this is one example of
how they are being undermined last month
12 trade unions protested against the
government's new labor reforms saying
they're unfair on employees and limits
their ability to negotiate minimum wages
[Music]
now the unions would have to agree to
and the workers would have to accept
whatever wages are decided by the
management of course then the workers
would question the relevance of trade
unions analysts say the government's new
regulations effectively limit the power
of unions and as they encourage wages to
be based on worker skills and where they
work they divide the workers and make it
difficult for the unions to negotiate
with employers the current fix of the
wage
various segments various regions various
interests as a result it is doulas to go
to a trade union
the unions accused the government of
working on behalf of employers some
analysts say weakening the trade unions
would limit employers ability to strike
a collective bargain in disputes with
workers others accuse the trades
unionists of being disruptive for the
sake of it of being highly politicized
and stalling India's economic growth
unionists fear a loss of their power and
influence
but look ma gawsh has not given up he
says his union is getting ready if
workers like him unlaid off and he's
preparing to join any protests are
tewara al Jazeera Kolkata West Bengal